[inaudible]
a lot of people are wondering these days
whether it's possible to put the word
Islam in the same sentence as democracy
and human rights and to tell you the
truth,
if there are not that many examples to
be optimistic about.
Even in a country like Turkey where they
have a guarantee of the separation of
church and state,
they are still moving towards and
Islamic theocracy.
Nevertheless,
there is one country that is escaping
this trends and that country is too,
right?
Yeah.
Smith 10 million inhabitants.
Tunisia is the cradle of the so called
Arab spring.
You know that phenomena that started in
the winter of 2011 anyway,
this is where everything started and
more specifically things started in the
city of city Bosiat it things kicked off
when a 26 year old fruit seller burned
himself to death as a form of protest in
front of a government building.
This is how a revolution spread all
across northern.
Yes,
I forgot.
And from here you probably do know the
rest of the story.
In Egypt,
they overthrew their dictator only for
him to be replaced by a man who is
probably even worse.
Libya is a failed state that has a high
probability of becoming a radical
Islamic country.
And as well,
let's just say it's probably best that
we don't talk about Syria.
Among all of this madness,
though,
Tunusia is an exception after rounds
thing.
Their dictator,
Aberdeen,
Ben Ali Dune is,
Ian's wrote a brand's new constitution,
which was inspired by French law.
This new tanks.
It allows freedom of speech and freedom
of religion,
but not only that,
now 20% of the country's parliamentary
seats are occupied by women.
This is a very big achievement if you
consider to nausea to any other Islamic
country,
why Tunisia has become one of the main
targets of Dash.
So far,
more than 73 people have died in three
separate terrorist attacks.
And this is what leads us to many
questions.
Cantonese,
he and liberal democracy survive in such
a harsh environment.
Can tunusia become a model for
neighboring countries?
Will the European Union help or damage
this democracy?
Well,
today we are going to answer all of
these questions for you,
but first we need to look a bit at the
history of tuners.
Yeah,
lights and shadows of abby met Ben
[inaudible] in 1955 at Tunusia got its
independence from France just like other
countries in the region,
the Republic of [inaudible],
the so called Arab socialism or Pan Arab
Islam.
This was an ideological cocktail that
mixed authoritarianism,
charismatic leaders,
a centralized economy,
and finally a secular state.
You might to even say it's an anti
religious state.
This ideology became very fashionable in
the area that brought as tyrants,
such as Gaddafi in Libya and NASA in
Egypt.
In the Tennessean case,
the man is the man you are seeing on the
screen now.
His name was happy,
but Bourguiba in summary has government
was famous for its corruption.
In summary,
has government was famous for its
corruption clientelism and it's
systematic devaluations of the national
currency,
the dinner.
It's really no wonder that the economy
eventually collapsed.
And so what was the outcome?
Well in 1987 presidents Bourguiba was it
the hospital recovering from a heart
attack?
It was at this point to that is prime
minister Aberdeen.
Ben Ali took his seat.
June is Ian's called this events the
medical cute Atar.
No blood was spills and actually there
was no violence whatsoever.
Even when Bourguiba left the hospital,
Ben Ali sent into a luxury mentioned
with a team of doctors and nurses to
take care of him.
Legend even says that he went to visit
the man often.
So you can see that this was a coup
guitar,
but you can see that it was one with a
lot of love and care.
So what did Ben Ali do?
Well,
during his mandate,
he sent that he would bring democracy to
Tunisia and while he did cool for
elections several times,
the problem was that in order to run in
the elections,
you needed the approval of 30 people
from the existing government party.
This means that in most of the cases,
well surprise,
surprise,
the only eligible candidates was one
from the government.
Thanks
soul of this Ben Ali Hell's power for 23
years,
23 years.
That of course continued the tradition
of corruption that the tune is Ian.
People have grown,
used to,
but now there is something positive we
should say about Mr Ben Ali and that is
his economic practice from the stars of
this rule.
He encouraged foreign investment in
this,
encouraged a loss of foreign companies
to establish themselves in Tunisia.
This is how several hotel chain started
up in the country.
You attracted by the great weather.
This led to tourism becoming tuners.
He main industry followed by the olive
industry.
And don't forget the latter of those
because we're going to be coming back to
it shortly.
So during those 20 years,
tennesseans actually managed to
multiplying the income by three.
In fact,
in 2010 Tunusia boasted over 6 million
tourists.
This is about half
the number who visited neighboring
Egypt's bar to do.
Keep in mind here that Egypt has,
well the pyramids and also where
population nine times the size of
Tunisia.
Hey,
close attention to the numbers here.
Tunusia has a population of 10 million
people and in a single year they hosted
6 million tourists.
So why am I emphasizing this quite so
much?
Well,
that's because tourists are much more
than an influx of money for the country.
They also bring with them another
culture.
Suddenly in a country which is majority
Islam,
it becomes normal for people to see
women walking around without scarves on
their heads.
But I miss actual people to be seen
kissing in the streets and for people to
be drinking alcohol.
There is no other Islamic country that
is quite so exposed to this level of
western culture.
So if you aren't one of those British
people,
you've got drunk in 18 izzy and hotel
well knew that you're doing your part
for Tunez cultural diversity.
Well,
thanks to this wider cultural exposure,
something quite extraordinary happened.
Craddick transition in Tunisia in 2010
the Tennessean economy,
it was on fire,
but the unemployment rate was 12% added
to this word,
corruption scandals and power abuses
under Ben Ali,
his regime.
Now,
all of these things were of course
hidden from the people in the local
press,
but due to the large amount of tourists,
a lot of foreign media was being brought
into the country and this educated the
people.
Now,
all of these things would never be
published in the local press,
but the foreign media,
they were reporting everything and it's
in a country with so much tourism,
what is written outside can very easily
be read inside so people knew what was
going on and they really didn't like it.
This land do demonstrations being
organized in several cities,
perhaps these protests wouldn't have
been so big if it wasn't for Mohammed
Bouazizi.
He was a 26 year old man who burned
himself to death in protest after police
took over.
History
me
is how the jasmine revolution started.
All of a sudden,
thousands of protestors gathered in
every tune is Ian city.
Now,
unlike other dictators,
Ben Ali didn't confront them,
but he simply lacks Ben Ali after 23
years in power and leaves Donisha after
this momentous occasion,
the presidents of the parliaments off
Tunusia forms a provisional governments
and fried over 500 political prisoners.
Not only that,
but some teen,
is he a dissidence who were living in
exile,
came back to the country among them.
But once this map Monsef Marzocchi,
he was the president of the Arab
Commission on Human Rights.
You might wonder now is whether the
Tunisia,
we are talking,
it's Islamic and the answer is no.
The donisha where
talking,
he's the more private.
So a year off the bow is easy,
burnt himself to death.
Junior Xeo was holding their first free
elections and our friends Marzouki would
become the first president.
So what exactly was the problem?
Well,
the president was from the Islamist
party talking about the [inaudible]
movement,
the Tunisia,
and then it's perhaps more moderate
version of the Islamic brotherhood.
Anytime when over 100 political parties
appeared in Nardo was the only one with
an efficient structure.
This is why the party one,
the majority of the seats in the tunas
in parliament,
this is particularly problematic if we
take into account that this was the
party that was going to be responsible
for crafting the new [inaudible]
constantly.
Sure.
So you might be wondering after this,
I wasn't that the tune is Ian
Constitution remains so secular.
Well,
okay.
Entrepeneur critical uncertainty is the
hardcore isn't a,
it's created these so called Islamic
leaks.
Visa of course supported the ruling
party in order to speed up the
Islamification of the country.
This led to violence on the streets and
yes,
Tanisha shocked by assassinations,
opposition leaders,
Mohamed [inaudible] and Chuck Green.
Meanwhile,
the income from tourism was falling
sharply.
No one wants to travel to a dangerous
country and this generated more and more
social unrest with this situation.
The secular parties created a common
front against Ennahda and this is how
the Islam is to block,
was forced to have secular politicians
in their cabinet.
Months later,
both the Islamists Leagues and the
Muslim Brotherhood were considered
terrorist organizations by the Tunisian
government.
And of course the most extreme
politicians had to leave the government
as well.
Actually in some months the whole
Ennahda movements and left the cabinet
and the left,
the decision making power in the hands
of the secular
did this with just one condition.
And that is that Islam must remain the
official religion in the new
constitution.
So what was the result of all of this?
Well,
the Newtonian constitution is not based
on sharia law and it includes both
freedom of religion and freedom of
speech,
but not only that,
it also guarantees a nonreligious
education.
Islam now holds only a symbolic position
in Tunisia.
The reality is that when it comes to
politics,
Tunisia is a secular nation,
new free media organizations within
formed and to watch followed.
This was the creation of one of the
strongest civil societies and the whole
of North Africa after this.
It is no surprise that during the
elections in 2014 Islamist parties lost
to the secular liberal coalition.
No,
still they believe me about the
influence of tourism in Tunisia.
Well,
we'll have a look at this electoral map
on this map.
You can see how the Islamists lost in
the regions that are closer to the
coast,
and this is because that's where all the
hotels and resorts are.
Hold on a second because things are
about to get a little agreement.
Ooh,
strengthening Tunisian democracy
months.
After two years,
he had published that constitution dash
or the Islamic state organized that
first terrorist attack against the El
Barrio museum.
This is one of the main tourist
attractions in there
country.
As I resolved,
the number of British rivals,
which looked set to break records in the
early months of 2015 has fallen by 93.2%
for the first five months of these
years.
After this two attacks followed and in
total 73 people were left to debt.
This is why teaching is Ian Government
has a security crisis as well as an
economic crisis and to one of them is
destroying their main industry,
which is why stories like this not quite
so important.
Donisha
do you offer $50 billion of projects to
foreign investors?
Not only that,
but the European Union has also
eliminated or fairs on the import of
Tennessee and olive oil.
As you know,
in the European Union,
agriculture is protected from foreign
markets,
but in the case of Tunisia,
it is essential in order to support that
all of industry.
As I said before,
he says the second largest industry in
the country behind tourism,
but it's a hold on it for a moment
because as you can probably imagine,
this didn't make the European farmers
too happy.
Especially those ones based in
[inaudible].
Yes,
save our quality.
Say no due to donation.
Oh,
well this is the specialty.
Funny.
You're given them.
Most of that oil that is labeled as a
made in Italy is actually produced in
Tunisia and then ships to Italy where it
is labeled and this is where the
political battle starts.
In Europe on the one hands,
it is crucial to help the teen is in
economy so they can maintain their
democracy,
but on the other hands,
a lot of European countries don't want
to lose their privileges.
Question is,
do you think Europe should open its
market to at Tunusia?
Do you think that it is an important
sacrifice to make in order to prevent
political unrest in the country?
And do you think June is here,
could become a model for neighboring
countries?
Well,
do let us know.
That's what the comment section below is
useful for.
[inaudible] of course,
do not forget that we upload brand new
videos like this every Monday and every
Thursday.
So do hit that subscribe button that is
on the screen as well as below the video
to be sure that you are notified about
those videos.
I'd also,
if you enjoyed this video,
please do give us a thumbs up and as
always,
I'll see you in the next video.